okay so you want to throw a professional
match in your eSport you think you'd be
subtle about it so you know you don't
get caught but in this case a
professional rocky league team threw a
pivotal series on the fly mid match and
because of that the entire squad was
dropped from their org and psionics the
developer of rocket League investigated
the situation and banned two players for
an entire year
[Music]
okay so if you're a fan of don't at me
subscribe to the channel like the video
and leave a comment below telling us
what kind of videos you want to see it
really helps us decide what content to
make okay now let's get back to the
controversy so team esperar an
Australian eSports or with a rocket
league team that competes in the oceanic
division of the our LCS and over the
weekend they competed in a best-of-five
series against fury to determine who
would make the upcoming playoffs so keep
that in mind it's a high-stakes series
with a lot on the line team ESPA coming
in here for the last game of the regular
season here before we had the playoffs
the game is ready let's get into it
what's in' I mean we had some great
rocket League today and with a game vibe
with so much is on the line you could go
aspirated before but then team a Spurs
captain and other player frenzy decided
to throw Game five of that series and
because of that the entire team was
dropped from their org psyonix launched
an investigation releasing their
competitive ruling on Tuesday which
states that both frenzy and delusion are
banned from competing in any psionic
sanctioned event for an entire year and
they have to forfeit their prize money
from that series so why the hell would
team s Birds sabotage their own playoff
chances well here's the thing because
the our LCS standings are determined by
how many games and individual team wins
and with the standings being so close
team Esper had to be theory three to
nothing or three one in order to make
the playoffs so basically if they lost
two games they were out of the playoffs
team s4 won the first two games and
things were looking good but fury
managed to make a comeback and they won
the next two games which means team a
Spurs playoff hopes they were over of
course now there are questions it's it's
how hot is it estimate gonna fight now
that they're out I mean of course they
want to move up in the positions a
little bit five or a little bit more
cache of course but the drive the the
drive to go to the playoffs it's not
really there anymore so the question is
can they fight hard enough to still take
the win here but this series was
important for another reason because it
decided the playoff fate of team
renegades who have been team espers
rivals all season if Esper won the
series three to two against fury it
wouldn't matter
they weren't making the playoffs but if
they lost the series it would give Fury
fifth place in the standings and edge
out renegades who would also not make
the playoffs and so with nothing left to
lose and their rivals playoff hopes in
their hands frenzy and delusion decided
to throw Game five of the series yeah
the kick open it might be the team s but
just don't want renegades in playoff or
D just miss his look but it's looking
like they're given the window furio's
not sure if this is allowed at first
caster smite and Watson were naturally
confused as to what was going on but
they pretty quickly realized some weird
[ __ ] was happening when team espera
missed multiple kickoffs and delusion
randomly sat in the corner before
scoring on his own goal well let's go
along with the assumption that espera is
playing the best they can here as we
continue the series as you can see
they're posting it back up they don't
get out yet all right so I've gone back
and forth with both of them and the
biggest takeaway from smite was the fact
that this series was shaping up to be
one of the biggest showdowns that the
region has ever seen and now well it's
just ended with match-fixing and after
scrubbing through the vod's reading
through chat logs and talking with the
tournament organizer psionics released a
competitive ruling on Tuesday and the
statement highlights their competitive
integrity rule 7.2 which reads quote
each player is expected to play to the
best of his or her ability at all times
during any match any form of unfair play
is prohibited by these rules and may
result in disciplinary action end quote
what's important to note about psyonix
is ruling is that it states that Steve
the third member of Team Esper had
nothing to do with throwing Game five
and therefore won't be punished at all
after psionics dropped the ruling
Delusion was obviously pretty pissed I
mean he just got banned for an entire
year so he took to Twitter lashing out
at psionics and the media for reportedly
not sharing his side of the story in the
replies to that tweet well people aren't
buying it also i DM him to talk to him
for this story and unfortunately he
never got back to me on the other hand
the community reaction to this ban has
been pretty positive and a lot of people
seem happy that psionics
taking a hard stance on the situation as
of right now team espera has yet to
release a statement but hours after the
series wrapped they dropped the entire
team without any mention of the
allegations and when I reached out to
team Esper I managed to talk to the orgs
founder a guy named Focus he said that
all of this has come out of nowhere and
he's just as confused as everyone else
she also stated that quote the player
agreements were drawing to a close and
as a result we let them go early to try
to avoid team Esper's name being
tarnished in the process Banquo and as
far as throwing Game five goes he says
that he only knows as much as the
players have told him which apparently
isn't much so the weird thing about this
situation is usually when somebody
decides to throw a match or match fix
it's decided ahead of time but after
team Esper lost the second game and they
were out of the playoffs it was this
weird spur-of-the-moment decision to
throw Game five and not only screw over
renegades but screw over themselves
seeing as they've been banned for an
entire year and they have to forfeit
their prize money from that series now
obviously we've seen far more famous
examples of match-fixing in eSports
often with money involved but you can't
underestimate how damaging this
situation is to the competitive
integrity of rocket League it's the
whole reason psionics came down as hard
as they did and at this point we don't
know if the illusion or frenzy are going
to try to appeal their ban in any way or
even if they're allowed to but we'll
update you on this situation as we know
more I've been watching literally got up
at 8:00 this morning through twitch on
made coffee like I'm just doing
everything I can to get the goddamn beta
key and it's not happening for me
4-valent
driving me nuts like I'm saying before I
was super intimidated by csgo and
overwatch because there's just so much
to learn and so much to pick up the
[ __ ] menus the menu is just they're
sublime you know
[Music]